there was a moment yesterday when I was
driving around that I saw stopped at a
red light certainly since my phone
sometimes it's connected to the car and
the sound goes up right
Jim Wyatt who covers the Tennessee
Titans took a video of the moment at
OTAs when the music you know how teams
play music during practices allowed to
get the team fired up or into it a
fascinating that the sound that came out
was something very familiar and near and
dear to my heart do we have that sound
can you play for me please
[Music]
I can name that tune in onenote hail to
the victors at Titans practice yes and
very odd well especially since the new
head coach of the Tennessee Titans by
way of the New England Patriots and the
Kansas City Chiefs a little bit miss
playing days and coaching days the
Houston Texans but originally by way of
the Ohio State is Mike Vrabel is he on
the phone line right now indeed he is
the head coach of the Tennessee Titans
joining us here on the Richardson show
for the first time as head coach at this
NDC Titus Mike Vrabel how are you coach
good guys how are you how did that slip
past the goalie there because I'm not in
charge of the the deejaying booth and so
I guess Taylor
infiltrated the playlist and was able to
slip that one in there through the five
hole and it only lasted about I didn't
know the beginning of it so it lasted
only until I started to recognize what
it actually was so then you cut it off
yeah we went to the next song over there
to our guy and I say stretch you know I
give the next song signal said what what
is the next song signal just a usual
it's you know I'd kind of like the
finger going here just kind of swiping
you know just kind of go to the next
song okay and yeah which which finger
coach index so you realize so what did
you save it a little on afterwards
nothing
what do you mean rested I hope you
enjoyed it because that'll be the last
time we have it oh my gosh see I guess
that's the first time a head coach
that's just another thing you have to
control right
don't you think is there I guess the
playlist yeah mmm yeah I mean we try to
play respectful music to me that's not
even respectful music oh my word oh gosh
so what was the next song I'm just not
sure I really don't it's all over the
place that there's rap there's country
there's rock there's okay but then they
hail to the victors is something that
we're gonna backburner that one
done as they say in the business so what
you're saying that's it okay how's
everything going dude how's everything
going down there in Tennessee first no
race well we're excited to get back
tomorrow I'm out on the field but it's
you know I think that guys you know are
into it they're into the new offensive
scheme the defensive schemes I think
they're trying to improve fundamentally
I think that you know they're trying to
learn to tame teammates that are new
either through the draft or through free
agency and so I think that that's going
well we've got aside a lot of young guys
in here that have improved and you know
our veterans have bought in as far as
trying to learn new techniques or learn
in a new scheme and in terms of what
fans should expect differently from what
they have seen from the Tennessee Titans
in previous administrations Hauer
how is Vrabel ball if you will going to
be any different you know I don't know
because I really don't want to compare
what is going on here and in the past
but the same message that have had to
our owner Amy and general manager John
and my team our players on our fans
since really I was lucky enough to be
the head coach here and hire staff was
that our job as coaches to make sure
that our players know what to do and
then play fast and aggressive and so
that however we have to teach them and
develop them and inspire them to do that
and that's what we're going to do in
terms of offensively then the scheme
that you're saying that might be new how
will it be different from you mean the
phrase exotic smashmouth that's been in
there for the last couple of years the
biggest thing for me is is that players
are more important in place and
teammates are more important than
players and by that I mean listen
everybody's got good place all right
everywhere you go college football
there's great players NFL is great place
but it's how do you get those players to
understand that scheme in that system
and making sure that they're the ones
that make it go everybody's there all
gurus defensively offensively we've got
good place you still got good plays
Jacksonville's got good plays and so how
do we get our players to
to buy in and understand and and really
they're the player they're the ones that
go out there and have to make it work
Mike Vrabel the head coach of the
Tennessee Titans here on the Rich Eisen
show have you caught yourself at any
point in time dropping a Belichick ISM
or sounding like bill in any way shape
you know I think that there's always
going to be people in your life that are
influential I'm I was lucky enough to
have invite my my high school football
coach down to spend a couple days with
us this week and and be in the meetings
and be at practice and just it was fun
to see him here and interact with our
team and just you know it was good for
me to kind of be with him and kind of
just go back and share those memories
and so I think when you go through life
you have people that are influential in
your career professionally and
personally don't build one of those guys
bill Carlo those guys or Myers one of
those guys look sickles one of those
guys Romeo Crennel is one of those guys
so there's a lot of people that I've
been lucky to be in contact with that
that I try to take some some positives
from and take some good things that help
me along in my playing career you know
my my coaching career
you left out Lloyd Carr on that list
Mike you left out Bo on I would I was
probably a Michigan lien people don't
know that like I try to tell everybody
but you know in December I was probably
a Michigan lean and and coach Clark came
to the house for dinner and we had bill
you know the old family dinner that the
visit in home visit and we that went
well and just at some point time and in
probably January just made the decision
to go to Ohio State I got to tell you
Mike I've heard this separately okay
I've heard this throughout you know cuz
as you know the the the state of Ohio
and I'll say it because again I
appreciate you calling in that state up
north okay that that there's always oh
hi oh guys Woodson and we can go on and
on Desmond etc that go up north and
exceed I heard you were potentially one
of them what why'd you why'd you stay
with all the Ohio State you know what it
was in my first football camp the only
football camp I ever went to was was was
in Ann Arbor I went to the minute
in football camping I didn't know
anything about recruiting or anything
and I just was running around out there
playing speed ball and next thing I know
you know Cam Cameron drives in a golf
cart he said Gary Moore would like to
see it his office I'm thinking what if
we did it would do something that a dorm
do we do something wrong
I'm nervous I'm scared to death and
you're not going there and he's like you
know I'm kind of watching you you know
play this game do his stuff and I would
like to offer you a scholarship to
Michigan and I'm thinking I didn't know
that this came with the deal I just came
up here to go to camp for a couple days
of my buddies and that was kind of the
beginning of recruiting and my best
friend in high school it always been a
huge Michigan fan and we went to the
games you know every other Saturday we
go to Michigan little obstacle in
Michigan on state jail felt comforted
with a coaching staff there Greg Madison
you know recruited me but you know in
the niño state was the right place for
me and you know still stay in contact
with those guys that recruited me still
talked to Greg still see Greg and you
know obviously you know Lloyd Carr and
then you know with Brady Hoke being
there and just know some of those guys
are good coaches you know and and are
you aware that you are the all-time Ohio
state leader in terms of catching
touchdown passes in a Super Bowl are you
aware of that Mike I did not I didn't
know that that was a stat that was kept
well I just decided to make one up
because I'm seeing the list here of
multiple touchdown receptions in Super
Bowl history
there's only 28 guys who have multiple
touchdown receptions in Super Bowl
history you're the only defender and I'm
looking at this list here off the top my
head i'd-- I think you're the only buck
I know buck I look at you look at you
about Santonio Holmes mmm he had one
gets the only had one he just had that
one and obviously there is big one
well Cardinals fans will place that in
dispute that is his leg Maisie
he never dotted that i but that's okay
we could just leave that one out there
let me ask you this one before I before
I let you go cuz again I really
appreciate you calling it in the middle
of all the stuff that's going on here in
the month of May
what's mariota's health like right now
coach you know I would say that the
health of the team right now is pretty
good I think that we've had most
everybody that's here in the building
available for practice and some guys go
through different parts of practice some
guys go through individual and walk
through and seven-on-seven and that's it
some guys go through the whole practice
some guys you know we try to make sure
that we concentrate on what guys can do
as opposed to what they can't and you
know Marcus is out there with with
everybody else so I would say that the
health of the team right now is it's
kind of where we want it and the guys
that aren't out there they're working
hard to get back and they're here early
and they're in the treat and training
room and taking part and whatever they
can great well and you've got a great
left tackle to keep them protected keep
that ball inside protected you got that
guy I heard I asked I said oh how they
never did you anything than where you
were
have fun with that but I appreciate the
time man thanks coach I appreciate it
no you bet I appreciate the time you got
you got thanks for calling that's Mike
Vrabel the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience